[Music]
and be careful new be careful submit it
by Hamburger Helper but I never had that
[ __ ] good Oh God sure you had it like at
a potluck or something but you didn't
know that's what it was because some
people make it in in that glass oven
tray all right Tim what do you got what
do you got for us okay okay oh and then
they came up with a mixtape Al's [ __ ]
dope oh yeah for April Fool's that one
day that one year's Hamburger Helper
yeah it was like a rat mixtape and it
was really good I thought you're gonna
say some [ __ ] like oh I love smelling
this [ __ ] through my friends window oh
yeah I roll over for childhood I
discover Hamburger Helper that's when I
was like 21 cuz they're like it's poor
people food I'm gonna help hurt like
they had this cheeseburger one that was
literally deconstructed cheeseburger
that you eat it was pretty pretty bomb
dude it's [ __ ] bowtie its bowtie [ __ ]
what is that bowtie didn't make all you
need is ground beef yep in a powder bag
it just just rip that [ __ ] open yeah
that [ __ ] was extra salty as [ __ ] dog
Hamburger Helper and there's a
rice-a-roni [ __ ] never had I love
dinners - oh dude same it's just way
better valve berry steak where the mac
and cheese and then like there's a
brownie but then like some of the mac
and cheese got into the brownie side so
you my favor altogether no I remember
this still back in the day so we were at
my friend Joe's house and y'all remember
this YouTube fantastic star named Victor
Kim yeah Victor Kim and I grew up
together and then there was like one
more [ __ ] hungry man dinner right it
was sounds very steak oh yo that looks
bomb he goes nope you guys can't have
any I was like Europe [ __ ] [ __ ] I
thought you can tell we all grew up with
parents that work a lot yeah
that's exactly what it was cuz I would
be left at home like there's a [ __ ] ton
food in the freezer go ahead and you
know what what what I asked for
I only asked for the broccoli I didn't
ask for the good [ __ ] and he said no I
like the one with the remember though
you know he's like I spent an hour
reading this [ __ ] story I said one
more thing yeah I do like the
highlighter vegetable from Yoshinoya to
do garden all right [ __ ]
glow-in-the-dark vegetables they're not
supposed to be that color
the neon cauliflower which is pretty
good a woman comes forward with her
story of how she was scouted for cults
while traveling solo I hate the fact
that no cults approach me but continue
you should go to Scientology building
they do not want me it's cuz we're not
in school anymore we're not traveling
alone and we don't look like someone
that's easily
you gotta come off culpable emotionally
vulnerable and like down on your luck
they go for people who's like down on
their luck with no money like needs some
sort of guidance and alone I'm just so
used to people soliciting and
panhandling and doing stuff I just stare
at people and go I don't have anything
for you oh my bad he's not gonna ask you
for directions yeah and when they start
coming my way I don't have nothing do
doozers god I was so [ __ ] cracked out
the other day he was wearing socks and
sandals with
sweats that are cut off at the ankles he
had a white I don't know how yet that's
not like sex what you have um clean his
white sweater oh yeah but it was a clean
white sweater I don't know how he didn't
get it dirty cuz he had the dirtiest oh
yeah he had dirty um construction
looking socks like it looked like he
walked through the Sahara Desert and the
socks were because of covered in [ __ ]
dust and then his hands were all like
filled with pain and [ __ ] he had black
ass teeth right in the front bald head
looked like a skinhead and stuff he came
up to me and then
I knew what he was gonna ask for and he
was like he was bright about the talk
and I said I don't have anything for you
and he was like he walked but he was so
cracked out that me and my family went
to the corner right and then he was
talking to himself kind of walking
around us as I heard and then he came
back again and he came back to me and he
said I said I don't have nothing for you
and he was like oh [ __ ] the homeless
people in LA man they're [ __ ] crazy
it would have been top if he curtsied or
something yes okay Ronson I was
pretending to be French yeah that was my
god yeah excuse me I'm from El francais
first of all l francais my dude yeah so
this story is about Ellis so back when
she was 19 years old and traveling solo
in Nepal she's Australian by the way if
you guys are curious she met this
charismatic spiritual gurus who promised
to save her from something it's a white
guy with dress it's a white guy with
dreads playing a didgeridoo slippers on
a dog wearing like a poncho yeah
poncho with the backpackers backpack
he's also seen him he's a girl in the
back and he wears either flip flops or
moccasins I don't believe in time yeah
she was fresh out of being in a Buddhist
retreat for an entire month in Nepal so
she stepped onto this mission my mom my
Sidhu she's like yeah she's there now
yeah probably
oh yes yes actually she goes to like
this there's a specific template likes
to go to in China where it's out in the
woods and there is no running hot water
so you have to go down to the well get
buckets of hot water walk up like I
don't know
or flight the stairwell eyes hot water
like a hot spoon no no you take the
water and then you heat it in your room
and then sorry everyone that lives there
lives like the old-school old fashioned
way and that's that's how my mom gets
her mental orgasm or something she got
her mental orgasm right there I bet you
she's meditating right now and watching
this [ __ ] watching she knows she's like
somebody talking [ __ ] yeah so alice is
saying that after she finished our
retreat she stepped into a crowded
square in Kathmandu so that place and so
she was saying that she was feeling the
kind of vulnerable you feel after a
month of meditating on emptiness what
she said I don't know what that feels
like how to can't meditate this a model
mm yeah I know so then she was just
saying that like after spending that
whole month there like being in this
very crowded space it was just a lot it
was just overwhelming and then so she's
saying all of a sudden someone grabbed
her arm and tried to pull her towards a
taxi and then suddenly like her skin
began to crawl and everything seemed to
stop and she looked across the square
and had chills cuz she saw that she was
being watched by a the most hypnotic
pair of eyes she had ever seen he that
this man looked like Antonio Banderas of
Antonio was a warlock dressed in
head-to-toe black dark hair cascaded
down his shoulders like black lava the
man seemed to have some kind of force
field around him that blocked everything
out
she was just describing all of this and
then so she was just saying that
tell me more I'm interested to see what
this fool I love how people's
perspective creates their reality in her
mind magic exists
and I love it I'm getting sucked into it
this literally sounds like the movie
Harry Potter Doctor Strange Doctor
Strange like the Shades of Grey but with
the Warlock yeah yeah he was like he was
a man with the Wizards Club I felt the
energy read it read it again but sexy
now and then it's 50 she's gonna be sexy
and medieval you know you ought to do
sectional make us women crap tell you
the rest of the story okay fine I just
thank you you look like Antonio bender
you see with the black black dressed in
head-to-toe dark hair can get it down
his shoulders like black that's right
you just made a whole bunch of 13 year
olds calm yeah it's true okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
there's 67 years old okay just think
about one viewer from North Korea that's
who used make um the one viewer from
North Korea you're creating so many
strokes from stroke within seconds a
well-dressed Western woman but with by
her side like a Western what do they
work together as a team
exactly she worked she introduced
herself as Claudia she says my master he
recognized you he says you are about to
get very sick physically and mentally my
master says he can help you and then
across the square the master nodded and
then finally Claudia invited Alice to go
talk to him but she was like you know
what Alice was like I'll just meet you
the next evening instead because it's
kind of weird so then she ended up
meeting that meeting then the next
evening she's kind of weird but I'm
gonna meet you anyway at night
I'm tired right now what I want to see
you I'm going to meet you in the middle
of the square but naked I will meet you
at 3:00 p.m. on the hour on the minute
on the second beam air and I will be
breast apart breasted oh you just see
I'll meet you in a fortnight from now I
will be the woman in a silk clothing
will you see through with your own eyes
yes she was saying that she felt special
being chosen early oh God
she's white no she's important she was
very conscious of the weight made her
feel and how shady everything was but
she was still intrigued so she was still
like went ahead with it she like Claudia
was just in the crowd looking for the
weakest person like the guy in the
corner they were like let's look for the
white girl in Nepal Westerner and she
stood out like a sore knee but she
sounds like the white girl because girls
this is the whitest girl yeah that's the
exact girl that I picked yeah she uses
all natural deodorant she doesn't shave
she has the shoes like the brown wig
hiking shoes with like the Rope thingy
oh yeah she has a backpack that steps
around here so this whole story took
place back in the 90s she was just
saying back when she was 19 so just to
clarify well I was just finding herself
I really like that they're spotting
people who just came down from the
mountain for that retreat meeting in
that area yeah and they're all looking
for the white people yeah they're in the
student pickup area and then the cult
people are white to just crush up with
white what about the Guru the Guru guys
she just graze him at San Antonio
benders look alike but I don't know he's
born
he's Morton spoke Latin like a baby yeah
she's also says like he has an accent
that she can't quite him yeah cuz they
made that [ __ ] up he brought it up he's
like Jack Black and [ __ ] yeah now not to
leave right yeah he made up his own Act
what if he's trying to do a Nepalese
accent but he's totally bit butchering
it and they're like what kind of
European are you anyway she ends up
going she meets them at this one
restaurant and then she's guided to go
upstairs to a private room and then she
sees all these women and like people in
this room like on the floor and it just
all look like really cool see and so she
ends up talking to him deep
I sounded like mimes it sounds like it
just sounds like a word that one yeah
she's just asking you have a lot of
questions and then she's just talking
about like she disguises on me more
detail I'm she's just saying like he
kept she kept asking him questions and
each time he would ask a question he
would she would ask a question he would
dodge it and then it looked like he was
getting frustrated because he didn't
want to be asked all these questions I
wasn't prepared for this interview yeah
long story short she didn't fall for the
[ __ ] because they were gonna get her
and she kind of did though lucky she did
I feel she was curious I think I would
have been curious I would be curious you
like okay let's see what you can swap
with that I'm gonna get [ __ ] murder
that's the difference between minorities
and white people white people are brave
they're invincible they're the ones that
investigate when they hear things happen
in the scary movies in the scary yeah
that's investigate all I'm saying is why
people are courageous who goes to the
middle of a third-world country -
because they need to find themselves and
live among the people and ride a scooter
all over town and not get raped or
anything happens who does like
handstands on craftsmanship I went to
like one of those countries I would
immediately get raped hello guys I hope
you guys enjoy the video please remember
to give us a big thumbs up and a like
like like and also when you guys sign on
YouTube make sure just kidding news is
the first thing you watch every single
day because we post videos every day
okay for more videos
[Music]